[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print
podcast on ramsey networks is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five the call is free and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it and it's going to start off this hour
in austin move i better put that right
jumping around here and there she is ann
is in austin texas to start off this
hour hey anne how are you
i'm doing fine thank you cool so i see
on my screen that george challenged you
to do something what have we gotten
ourselves into here
well i had a credit card question and i
knew he was going to chew me out for
using them but i didn't it was a
question
but it was like something that had
bugged me i don't remember even what it
was now but
he
was kind enough
to take some extra time with me and give
me a challenge to try to live
a month without them
and you did it and
well
i did it because he asked me to i didn't
do it because i was convinced it would
work ah
but you're willing to
play along
okay so you went a month with no credit
card use i i take it you used a debit
card
no no use cash
and i ordered a debit card oh cool
so no plastic transactions for a month
yes
wow i'm impressed that's hardcore okay
so tell us about it what happened
well what happened was
i i was a little bit scared actually
because i realized i was going to have
to pay
for my credit cards that i'd used last
month and take care of my expenses for
this month all at one time
and i go hmm
this may be interesting and you know
what happened i got this little
feeling or something i don't know
whether i don't know what it was but i
just felt this blend between
under my wings and i went i can do this
i could do it so i decided i was going
to do it and i was going to do it right
okay so
yeah
so i took the i just i just
i just jumped into it right away and you
know what the strangest things happened
first of all when i went to the grocery
store
i didn't look left or right because i
know these are professional people that
are trying to distract me that's right
i'm not a professional in this area so i
need to
not be tempted and i also gave myself 10
minutes to be in the grocery store and
out
wow because you're using your own money
you got it and you have to peel it off
like you're like you're bleeding or
something to give it to them or you can
just flash them apart when you hand it
over that cash it hurt
because you you left but it surprised it
was even better than that when i gave
her the money
she gave me change
and you're like i forgot that you can
get change
chase i had it in my hand i go what do i
do with this wow it was it was so did
you you spent less money you're telling
us that you spent less money because you
used cash if you don't put anything in
your budget buggy
you don't have much to pay for
what a concept so you're saying when you
use a credit card it was like
supermarket sweep you were just filling
up that card as fast as you could and it
felt like you were getting it all for
free
and i was doing a good job too
oh and you're hilarious well thank you
for humoring us and doing this
experiment so has it changed are you
going to go back to credit cards
[Laughter]
well my dog had to go to the vet this
month and i hadn't expected that that
bill and i i was i was a little bit
concerned but i paid for it out of the
change that was in my purse now
i'd gotten a focus that i hadn't had for
a long time so did you keep track and of
how much you saved by using cash using
your own
money i didn't have time i was putting
money in my purse so often i didn't have
time to keep the records but i can now
oh that's that's an awesome experiment
so it sounds like you've realized the
power of using your own money of using
cash it you make decisions differently
that was my whole point with you doing
this experiment
exactly i i understood it and i
appreciate the fact that i know you
can't give a challenge to everyone
not individually but i appreciate that
you did it for me you did exactly what i
needed exactly but i needed it i love
that anne thank you for the call that is
so cool
i hope all of america takes the
challenge one month without credit cards
and see how it changes the way that you
spend well she actually went further
than you asked her to yeah you said get
a debit card and she hadn't even gotten
it yet so she does a pure cash month
no plastic at all which is the best i
mean that'll really make you feel yeah i
mean you want to get pissed off about
filling up your car try walking all the
way into the market and laying down
uncle benjamin franklin a couple of
times after you paid it off now you're
really getting bullied that'll get you
political right there that'll get you
angry calling your senators after that
angry
oh my goodness well dave you've been
dealing with this for 30 years now this
whole argument of you spend more on a
credit card you make decisions
differently when you use other people's
money and it affects you negatively for
your financial future now the there's
tons of studies that show that the pain
centers of the brain are activated when
you spend cash
it literally
hurts
and when you spend with a card even a
debit card it's just like
no brain activity no brain but no brain
activity right so uh but the you know no
that's all kidding aside there there's
you know total day and rachel brought us
something many many years ago and i
hadn't ever thought about it even though
i've been teaching by then this whole
idea for decades
when
when you're a kid
and you have a toy and your friend wants
a toy and you trade
you give him your toy and
there's a there's a visual transaction
in u1 you ran it back in yours right
with a
purchase you're taking something
and you give them your money
and
they keep your money and you keep their
thing
just like a trade it's greenbacks for
stuff you see a trade
when you are purchasing something with
plastic you take their stuff
hand them your plastic and they hand it
back to you you leave with both things
see that seems that seems a little bit
childish when you think about it but you
know what there's no trade there's no
transaction here because i'm getting
both things
the thing i came for and the thing i
came in with i leave with the plastic
and the thing when i'd use money i don't
leave with the money yeah i just leave
with the thing
and there's something visually that
happens inside of our brains there that
affects our emotions affects our spirit
and it lowers the fact that we realize
we just spent money i think that's
what's happening in congress oh my
goodness yes and it's really hard to go
into debt when you don't have the option
to because your bank account said empty
but it's easy when you've got the
lenders going we'll happily give you as
much money as you'd like card denied
when you have a debit card typically
means you don't have the money
it's a whole idea
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at eight eight
two five five
two two five we get it folks when you're
worried about money
it's overwhelming it's all consuming
money worries are
some of the worst forms of anxiety that
dr john deloney deals with
um if you don't have enough pay your
bills you get that little sweat in your
palms and right above your lip and right
above your eyes and
always in your checkbook it's always on
your mind
but you shouldn't have to live with that
kind of stress
you work too hard to live like that
and good news is you don't have to if
you follow a proven plan you'll discover
peace
with your money that's why we call it
financial peace
university and we'll show you the same
plan that's helped almost 10 million
people learn how to get on a budget save
get out of debt spend wisely build
wealth be outrageously generous
and short how to handle money right
and it's a great time to take the course
we just updated a ton of the content
it's rachel cruz me and new stuff with
george camel and dr john delony
yeah the course is the best it's ever
been right now so to si decide today
that you are done
letting money stress rule your life
listen i can't make inflation go away
and i can't fix recessions
but i can show you how to weather the
storm i can show you how to prosper in
good times and in bad times
go to ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
ramsey solutions com fpu financial peace
university bridgette's in midland texas
hi bridget how are you
hi guys thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um
so i was wondering if i should take out
a mortgage and buy a house or
um continue working and save up
and just pay pay cash for a house my
ultimate goal is to go to crna school
which is a three-year program
and
i am not able to work during that time
because it's a very rigid program
and
so here are my numbers
i'm single with no kids i'm 27 years old
i am an rn and i travel for work
i have an income of so far because my my
income varies
depending on the contract that i have
so right now
so far i have
137 000 so far
my emergency fund is is
already done i have it there um i'm debt
free i have no student loans no car loan
i just have my rent plus my bills how
much is your rent
a thousand and one hundred and see crna
schools how long two years
three years three years and what's it
cost a year
um i was looking it up and it said a
total of uh
100 000.
a total
at one particular school
yeah this is in houston yeah yeah okay
so 100 000 in tuition and books or does
that include living expenses
with living expenses as well
really
you only need a hundred thousand dollars
you make 137 and you're single
yeah and my savings is eighty four
thousand dollars i mean 84
yeah thousand dollars and uh you have 84
000 already saved
yes wow
okay so what's the deal go to school i
mean you work six more months and then
go to school what does the house have to
do with this
um
uh because i don't want to go to school
yet i'm still because i'm racing my
little brother and he's still in school
so i have to wait for him to get um to
go to college which should be in about
seven years so
in the meantime i'm taking care of him
and
i just want to buy a house and you know
build equity and with the money that i
have i don't have to get take out loans
and
um because my ultimate goal is to sell
this house live in houston and not
having to pay rent just the bills and
with whatever money left i have just
paid you know bills and tuition and all
of that
so this is a 10-year journey you said
seven more years three let's stop
your little brother is
seven years old
no he's 12.
he's 12. so seven more years he'll be
gone you're saying okay right yeah
man you're amazing you took on the
raising of your little brother what
happened to your parents
um
there my dad is just not in the picture
and our mom passed away about five years
ago
you're amazing
okay so who takes care of your little
brother now he goes to school during the
day
and you have like after school you have
like after school care
uh no my sister has been helping me out
with him when i travel
and go on my contracts and then when i
come back i how long are you on a
contract
uh it depends so when covert was at its
peak i was doing like eight week
contracts
where is your sister in midland as well
yes
we live together so that's why my my
rent is a little high because i rent a
three bedroom yeah what does your sister
do for a living
right now she just got separated from
her baby daddy and
so she's just helping with racing the
kids because she's got three kids on her
own
she's about to go to school full time
this upcoming fall
and um
that's where we're at i know how old is
she
she's 23.
so you're the mama this whole bunch
aren't you
um
you know what would work
since you're since you're committed to
this plan
load up the whole bunch and go to
houston now
you kick everybody yeah and and you know
well within six months you don't do it
right now
uh your sister's not working
so she can land where you tell her to if
you're taking care of her too
and she's going to start school she can
start school in houston as easy as she
can in midland houston's where you can
get your crn n a
but um
if you can save up enough to take care
of you're saying that the hundred
thousand recover your living expenses
including your rent right
well my rent will be paid off i was
thinking you know no you're not gonna
pay off the house and go to crno you
don't have the money
you only got a hundred thousand
you need a hundred thousand for school
that leaves zip for a house do you own
the house you're in
no i rent yeah i thought so
yeah i'm trying to keep you from having
to put your life on hold for the
responsibility that you took on for your
brother and your sister
and that's kind of why i'm thinking i'm
taking them all to houston sister can
take care of her kids and little brother
while you go to school
in return you help support them and take
care of them which is what you've done
and you could execute that next spring
next spring yeah i mean because you can
probably save another 50 grand by spring
can't you
oh yeah yeah that's what i would do and
then the house gets that way it's not a
seven year plan
okay so
if you were this boy's mama
you would not put your life on hold as
his mama and you're playing mama now
you've taken over the care of him you
would go ahead and figure out a way to
go to school and you take him with you
and go to school and the only thing is
who's taking care of him now sister well
you're taking care of her so that's a
fair trade she can just load up and go
with you i'm going to save another 50
grand or more by next spring
and then i'm going to school and take
them all with you
they don't really have a say in the
matter you're the one taking care of
everybody they're going to go where you
tell them to they're under your roof and
i would put the house on pause at that
point and yes
you need to go to school
because that's going to increase your
income as well which is only going to
help later on with the house purchase
and then when you finish school in three
years and your sister has finished
school in three years and she can get
out on her own become sustainable your
little brother will almost be there
and then we can start talking about
buying a house at that point
and i don't know what will happen in
your personal life during that period of
time either
hopefully your entire personal life
won't be on hold
you're an amazing young woman you have
taken on a tremendous responsibility
with a big heart thank you for doing
that yeah uh thank you for being that
kind of person that little boy
has a hero in his life and it's his
older sister
and so uh however i think there's a way
you can manipulate these facts
tactically to not have to put your life
on hold for seven years
i think i think we just you know we do
what we all do with our kids we drag
them through the adventure
they go along for the adventure that's
how the kiddo thing works
and um
yeah i think i would wow what an
interesting
situation and what a beautiful woman man
i mean it's impressive making bank she's
working her tail off taking care of the
family everybody can depend on her
because she's that kind of gal way to go
bridgette this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
come by and visit ramsey solutions if
you're in the nashville area we've got a
huge lobby and visitor center free
coffee free
homemade chocolate chip cookies that are
from the devil and um their temptation
is unbelievable
and blaming the devil david well you got
to blame somebody you can't blame myself
because i must be a victim of something
so uh like my own sweet tooth or
something george campbell ramsey
personalities my co-host in the lobby of
ramsey solutions we do the show every
day from 1 to 4 central and you can come
and watch us do the show i'm not sure
exactly why that's exciting but people
do it all the time
and it's free so you can you can't
really argue about the price
and in that lobby is a debt-free stage
that michael and julie are on hey guys
how are you we're good dave how are you
welcome where do you all live so we live
in sdk to oregon it's outside of
portland oregon oh wow that's a bit of a
haul to nashville how much debt have you
paid off we paid off 136
397 dollars way to go how long did this
take uh two years eight months
all right and what was your range of
income during that two years and eight
months we started out 172 went up to 264
and then down to 257
cool what do y'all do for a living so i
retired out of the department of
homeland security in portland uh a year
ago i was at the writing wow and uh
since we own a medical clinic together
i'm now the medical administrator and
julie is the medical director oh very
cool okay yeah i'm a family nurse
practitioner medical director of
integrative primary care clinic oh my
goodness okay
good good good well welcome what kind of
debt was the 136 000. oh dave we had a
little bit of everything we started with
a
retirement loan we had a addition loan
we bought a home that was probably way
over what we should have done
we had two lines of credit to keep our
business open um
we had a parent plus loan we had a
second mortgage and we had two credit
cards for alaska my lord y'all were
normal
normal oh my gosh and you paid every bit
of that off yes including your house no
oh everything but the house everything
for the house good good two years and
eight months that's pretty intense it
was a lot dave we
when we started two years eight months
ago we had a met with a lawyer whether
we should close on the business and go
bankrupt wow
so and you turned it completely around
yeah now the business is worth 300 000.
[Laughter]
i hate it when that happens my way to go
you guys
okay so we're trying to figure out if
this thing's belly up you retire jump in
with both feet and of course julie's
already got the thing running you kick
it and the tail make it go yes and you
made some serious money yes during that
time uh which is great you turned the
business around but in the midst of that
you also say we're getting out of debt
because we don't be here again no never
so what initiated that part of this
journey dave we were davish we'd done it
once before 2009 and then we've i'm
addicted to debt
so i've we've started bad habits again
and so julie it really is his fault yes
not so much
i had the belief that you know i always
paid my bills
but i never really knew how to save and
so when we hit a
issue with the business
a contract pulled out with the state and
i lost about 50 percent of our income so
i had a lot of hard conversations with
the medical providers and
with our family too um so a lot of
humility and surrender
yeah that's tough that's a hard that's a
hard uh
corner to turn
and uh the fact that you did it there's
a lot of stress in the last two years
yeah what were those sacrifices like you
guys made where you decided we're not
going to be in this position again well
we
we met with a ramsey certified coach
um really encourages me a eager off
shout out to you yeah we had joined fpo
but uh
we started uh our different attorney we
got a thousand dollars and immediately
the transmission went on our vw of
course and then at the very end of it uh
the transmission went out on my 88 chevy
you're 88.
chevy
still driving it i guess it was about
time yeah it's still going
that car right there is a classic man
yeah i love it a two-tone 88 pickup yup
man that's a beast i love it well i'm
sorry it didn't live
is back up running it's got a new engine
new transmission oh you fixed it all up
it will not die wow this is awesome the
second life the zombie truck lives wow
oh it's cheaper than buying oh yeah oh
yeah for sure yeah anything we're still
working on our um
what is it the three months of savings
yeah yeah so we're almost there
and we're aiming to pay off the house in
the next five to six years wow and
you'll have a hundred thousand dollars
in retained earnings sitting over in the
business one of these days so if you
ever hit another little bump it will it
won't be a bump you don't thank you yeah
liquid cash there too of course way to
go you guys
how does it feel
um i still feel like an avalanche is
behind me
but um i have a lot more tools now and
humili i said humility and just keeping
our sights on our goals and
leaning into our relationships with god
yeah amen
thank you dude and you went through a
lot with your career change as well
because like you said you were in the
middle of all the protests and
the violence and everything else and you
step aside from that and walk into a
whole different kind of violence yep and
then uh
15 000 clinics like ours closed during
the pandemic
so we kept open and i credit julie for
that yeah so i feel stronger about
leading the clinic than i ever have
before
and so we went from
bankruptcy card given to us to um is it
300 000 net worth millionaires yeah and
wow i mean that occurred to us in
february as we're coming into paying
this off it's like we looked at our
assets and we went oh my gosh look at
that who knew yeah we thought we were
just surviving and here we ended up you
know that's what happens when you do
something like this so well done y'all
very well played what a turnaround all
right what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is
uh
yeah keep your sights on the goal
and work hard change your mindset you
can do it um we're proof you know i'm 53
julie's 52 so if we can do it our stage
um do it earlier i'd really recommend
that yeah we could have done this a lot
sooner yeah i hear you but we have hope
for the future now yeah in our
retirement good
good that's why we're here i'm glad we
helped good for y'all well done you're
heroes excellent excellent job got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
because you've just become one there you
go
and a copy of total money makeover for
you to give away to somebody who's
scared and struggling like you were i
could show them a light at the end of
the tunnel and a a one-year membership
to financial peace university with the
new videos with george and dr john
deloney and rachel cruz and me best fpu
we've ever done right now out there so
get you signed up for every bit of that
congratulations you two very very proud
of you you're amazing thank you it's
quite a journey you've been on wow quite
a lot of tr life transition i mean just
one thing after another like boom boom
boom boom parrots their business
very well done michael and julie
portland oregon 136 000 paid off in two
years eight months making 172 264 to 257
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i
love it that is
fabulous
man that's very well done
very very well done
it's not too late to go all in well a
ramsay-ish ish on a program that works
it's not going to do with me but the um
i kind of resist that dave ish thing but
ramsay-ish i'll go with because that's
our what we all teach here right and uh
the point is is that um the nuances the
detail of the stuff we teach you if
you'll submit to every one of those and
do them the reason those items are there
in the baby steps and and the little
things around it like work with your
spouse like combine your finances don't
try to do like roommate thing and all
that stuff when you do all those things
together you get rid of your whole life
policy it's not a baby step but you get
your term insurance in place get rid of
that rip off stuff you know you you keep
doing all the different little things it
changes everything and these guys right
here man
what what is
hard to
listen to in three or four minutes here
is with what he went through with his
career facing all the violence and
everything else and then they finance
they face this financial violence with
the state pulling a contract out almost
losing their business
and then the two of them come together
and he's driving this 88 car i mean this
is these are people that have walked
through stress so deep you could smell
it i mean it's unbelievable and they
still killed it
very very they're warriors man
absolutely very strong very strong
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from blinds.com
[Music]
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure or you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free free samples free
shipping new promos all the time it's a
great american company check them out
blinds.com
today's question comes from james in
california he says dave out of curiosity
specifically how did you make your first
million
after your bankruptcy
hmm that's a good ques i don't even know
the story
i'm not sure i do
take us back
so this was back in 88 so i filed
bankruptcy in september of 88 and what i
did after that was i went back to doing
real estate deals
only i couldn't
uh buy real estate anymore because i had
no credit and no money so
what i would do is tie up a deal and
then sell the contract to another
investor that used to be a competitor of
mine but we're friends
and so i did you know
what you might call a dry flip in other
words i sell the contract positions so i
go contract for a house that's worth 200
000 i would contract for it for 110 and
sell it to a buddy of mine for 10 000
bucks and he could close on you have 120
in it right it's still 200 000 house so
i'm still doing foreclosure deals i got
back to doing
six figures in 89 again i was back
making over a hundred thousand a year
doing that
but i had a bunch of irs debt to clean
up because that doesn't bankrupt and a
few other things to clean up
and it took about a year and a half two
years to clean that up so i'm trying to
think that maybe i kept doing that um
i'm trying to think
if i got my net worth to a million again
before we started doing financial peace
i might not have
so have you started this actually really
starting this business slowed that down
because i made less the first year
i did the fin i did financial piece it
was called life after that and i was
doing the radio show the radio show was
losing money
um
my taxable income was in half the first
i made 120 000 a year before i made 60
000 a year after wow first year opened
this business
and my income went in half so that
slowed it down
so it would have been a couple of years
after i got this going uh you know we're
starting to get a little bit of income
out of this income came bomb back up
over time of course because you started
selling the original financial piece
book and are you doing seminars and you
know the 13 15 week however long it was
yeah classes sharon and i lived on
nothing
even though we were out of debt by then
i mean we paid off the bankruptcy we
paid off the uh
everything we were completely clear but
we were just done and so we just lived
on nothing and just piled up money
and uh because we wanted both wanted the
security of that margin and so
what
how did i make my first million so
uh income
and thrift
is how i did it so it was not in the
stock market at that point no no i mean
well i had some i had uh i mean we had
our 401k not 401k we had roth iras not
they weren't even roth iras in those
days just irs i had iras in those days
going kids college funds going um and
i'm just chunking money and stuff like
that is in that
um
didn't even have any real estate except
our own got the house paid off
uh so yeah i was i was probably three or
four years into this business
before i hit another network it was
mostly earned income from mostly earned
income and not spending any of it yeah
none of it i mean we didn't do anything
we're still driving junk cars we're
still
way past what we teach people to do
we teach you once you get the baby steps
three four five
six or four five six that you can
lighten up and save up and buy a car and
lighten up save up and go on vacation we
didn't
we didn't we just piled up at what point
were the baby steps developed to where
you were you were following them
uh
post bankruptcy oh i didn't follow them
uh post bankruptcy because they did i
hadn't invented them i mean i hadn't
laid all that out when i started
teaching when i started learning
after the bankruptcy god's ways of
handling money what the bible says and
grandma's ways these basic principles
live on lesson you make
always be generous live on a written
plan
um
always be saving and investing and no
debt at all and those basic five
principles when i started living those
out and then i started trying to get
other people to live them out they would
start to say okay yeah but where do i
start
they needed it
i started a little counseling ministry
at our church i started teaching a
sunday school class on those materials
and people would say okay so what do you
do first man i mean do you do you do you
do you do you get out of debt first or
do you put money in your in your
retirement first and um
you know but by then i was sure that the
bigger blocker because i'd experienced
it personally was debt that if you could
get out of debt then you don't have any
payments now you've got money to build
net worth which is what happened to me
yeah okay you know i got out of debt
and with a bankruptcy and then paying
off the irs and the other stuff
and then once all that was cleared as
long as i made money and didn't spend it
i could build a net worth i could build
i could build a pile of money and that's
what i did and so i i thought okay we
gotta get people out of debt first but
the paying off the house was
too big a thing
to put in the early stages because first
thing's a thousand dollars right and
then pay off the house is the second
thing so we separated the house debt
from the other debt and put it at the
end yeah over in baby step six and we
knew that you didn't need to start
investing in your 401k until you had an
emergency fund because i was running
into people all the time that had no
money except in their retirement and
then they'd get in a pinch and cash out
their retirement
and let me tell you a 401 k is a lousy
emergency fund because when you cash it
out you get your taxes plus a 10
hit you know it's a 30 or 40 hit
cashing out your 401k to fix your
transmission
or to uh pay the house payment because
you got laid off
and uh you know whatever the emergency
is a 401 k is a lousy rainy day fund so
funding up to 401 but i get a match i
know but you're broke
i don't care if you get a match you're
freaking broke and you're going to use
the 401k when something bad happens
because you got no money so we bet baby
step three is invented actually baby
step one wasn't there you were just
going get out of that get out of debt it
was get out of debt do the emergency
fund and
and what would happen is as people were
working that baby step two
something would come along that was
little
like a a tire would blow out or
something or a kid would get sick and
it's a 600 700 thing or something and
that little six or seven hundred dollar
thing would take all the wind out of
themselves and then quit they would stop
their debt snowball
so we figured out that we gave him a
little bit of breathing room a starter
emergency fund and baby step one was
born
but the original baby steps when i first
started teaching him there wasn't that
so this evolved over your experience
coaching people being on not in 25 years
but i mean but but it evolved over a
period of time in the early days of
massaging this material and learning how
to do it it evolved but no i didn't
follow the baby steps they weren't there
all i knew was i'd read the bible and
they said don't borrow money and i've
been bankrupt so i figured out that the
truth right so i don't borrow money
anymore bomb i'm done you know and i
always have an emergency fund why
because sharon will leave if i don't
have one you know it's that simple she's
not going to be without money again
she's had enough of that she was
terrorized by that yeah she's not going
back so you get you know you get the
whole security gland issue around the
emergency fund that all pops up that's
such an interesting question james thank
you in california thank you very much i
hadn't even thought about it i never
thought about where the first million
came from um and then uh
and then you know
fast forward several years i had a lot
of money by then and 2008 hit and we
bought
oh man we bought
probably a hundred million dollars worth
of real estate for 15 million dollars
wow
and so and you know and it all came back
of course and then some
so that real estate has been a big part
of the building well like the way beyond
the first million or even 10 million you
know by then i had net worth 10 20
million dollars probably but uh i dumped
every i you know we we cleaned the table
off we took the chips off the table when
the when the real estate dove in 2008
and you could buy it for 15 cents on the
dollar and i still got all of that i
never sold any of it so um pretty
incredible that was a home run but the
first million is the hardest yeah by far
wow by far and these principles once you
got these baby steps dialed in and over
time you went oh it works but you know
what i'm from baby steps i didn't i did
not even follow the baby steps
millionaires i think path because
we were more intense than the baby steps
in terms of we didn't do nothing until
we got back up there
and um
the other thing i didn't do is i
i did get the house paid off because i
don't borrow money um but the um
but the 401k hadn't had time
to germinate the roth iras didn't have
time to germinate and grow and compound
and so they weren't that big a part of
it it was just literally make income
spend nothing make income spend nothing
until you get the pain far enough in the
rear view mirror
and then we can move forward but that
was a whole lot more intense
and raw than
than i asked other people to do to get
there baby steps millionaire is more the
formula to get there well thanks for
taking us back very interesting thank
you james that's good stuff this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print and
the entree leadership podcast both on
the ramsey networks be sure and tune in
we're here to help you the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five melanie is in omaha nebraska hi
melanie how are you
good afternoon how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um okay so i am the geek in my marriage
and
i also
work in the banking industry
and i am stuck i don't i can't make a
decision so i need you to help me
we can we can help we have an opinion i
promise
i don't even know what it is but we have
an opinion i'm sure
yeah okay so we were doing ruby really
well about four years ago and then just
this last spring hit us really hard and
kind of put it upside down
so i am trying to decide
whether or not to get a heloc and i'm
thinking about doing it for the purpose
of consolidating high interest rate debt
my pros are a lower interest rate to
knock out credit card debt with higher
interest rate and then beat the system
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
throw down principal payments before the
end of each billing cycle to make the
debt go down faster and then less
interest will go towards
what the heloc is my cons are right now
my current dti is 55 it needs to be
below 45
to qualify in order for me to do that i
will have to tie in a car loan that
we
acquired this year but that car loan is
at a fixed
4.75
and with the way that the interest rate
keeps going up with wall street i don't
know if putting that car loan over into
a heloc is a smart decision or a dumb
decision
but i was able to call the credit card
company yesterday and negotiate that
24.99
down to
16.99 for a year only what would dave do
what's the balance on the car
the car is 45 000.
what's your household income
um so this is going to be a little
finicky um to gather my husband and i
make a hundred and five thousand dollars
a year but i have a side job that's kind
of under the table and i can bring in an
extra forty thousand dollars
okay and what is how much credit card
debt do you have
15.
okay what other debt do you have
other than your house um
so
we literally drove both of our cars
until the wheels fell off and it
happened exactly a month apart this
spring
we made a family trip to go down to
texas to see some family down there and
i kid you not a week before we went the
engine blew in our 2012 traverse and i
tried everything i could to fix it
i used all of our expenses and then i
ended up putting more money on the
credit card which is why it went up it
got to the point where the mechanic was
like just stop it's not going to happen
and i'm like fine so then we ended up
getting that new traverse
not new but a used traverse
and
um and then
our other car which was a two thousand
and
ten pontiac you have forty five thousand
on one car fifteen thousand in credit
card debt and what other debt
um we have another car with fifteen
thousand
and then um our mortgage is three
eighteen three hundred eighteen thousand
okay no you don't need a home equity
loan you need to sell a 45 000 car
that's insanity
yeah you're broke
and you're trying to fix this with
interest rates because you did a stupid
but over purchase because you were
dramified
correct yeah
so i'm looking at
75 000 worth of debt total correct
outside of the house so if we get rid of
the car
and we get you something reasonable you
know five thousand dollar car
that leaves you with
about thirty thousand left what's the
car worth that's why you have 15 000
loan on it
i'm driving it and i'm gonna take this
140 000 and clean this mess up on beans
and rice rice and beans you got a great
income you don't have an interest rate
problem you have a lifestyle problem
correct
cut your lifestyle to nothing
brand new car payments for six years
scorched earth you don't need this car
payment for six years you need to be out
of debt in one year
no we didn't have car payments for six
years well until you lost your mind
and then you went through then you went
through the the crazy period of your
life
when you went crazy
and now you got yourself in sixty
thousand dollars in car debt
yeah a home equity loan doesn't fix that
getting rid of the cars fixes it or
getting rid of the debt fixes it and you
can't get rid of the debt soon enough to
suit me if you keep the 45 000 car so
i'm moving way down in car
no vacations no eating out
scorched earth
no spending on anything and 140 000 will
pay off 30 000
inside of a year pretty easy actually
yeah are you guys doing any investing
right now
no okay do you have any money in savings
um we did until
we threw it all at trying to save that
other car
okay so you don't have any money in
savings right now
no okay
well let's get you a thousand dollar
starter emergency fund and after that
we're selling this car today and beyond
that you got 140 grand income we're
going to pay off 30. you're going to
drive around to beat your car
and uh we'll clean this mess up real
quick with that kind of income here's
the thing melanie you're trained as a
banker in finance at some level in order
to be in the job that you're in and the
thing that we're taught in academia is
that interest rate is everything and if
we can simply cut the interest rate we
can solve all these problems and so you
called and negotiated 24 down to 16
24.99 down to 1699. that was a good move
by the way excellent job uh but here's
the thing
interest rate mathematically is
irrelevant when you're going to pay it
all off in one year
correct
so the home equity loan doesn't solve
anything what the home equity loan does
it's very dangerous
is it moves everything over onto your
home and you feel like you did something
and you drag this mess out for five
years instead of cleaning it up in 12
months
okay all right
that's exactly what i was thinking yeah
but we've been going back and forth home
equity alone is a form of it's a form of
denial
yes you're treating the symptom which is
the debt instead of the problem which is
what caused the debt
and you fix the problem with the
cutting the in or cutting the out go to
zero
cranking up the side hustle
and cranking down life for one year
and and you know undoing the big dumb
decision which was the forty five
thousand dollar car
and it's painful people are gonna think
you've lost your mind and what you're
gonna wonder gosh man i'm getting rid of
this car my failure you're not a failure
you're just me you just made a mistake
and you're fixing the mistake
i've done a lot dumber things than what
you did but this was dumb
it's on it's on the dumb list
so um but but you're not dumb you just
did a dumb thing there's two different
things i've done i'm not done but i've
done a lot of dumb things and george
george don't get me started don't tell
me how many dumb things he's done so but
i haven't done the heloc that one hasn't
uh never tricked me oh i had i did help
that's dan that put your home at risk
back in my old real estate investing
days when i borrowed everything in sight
i he locked everything
and then i unlocked it and locked it
again
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well
in 2020 house prices went up 29 and 21
they went up 18
this year they're gonna go up eight
percent next year most people are
predicting four to five percent that
means your old insurance policy may not
have you with enough coverage
homeowners insurance does not go up as
the value of your house does unless you
cause it to so you need to contact your
insurance agent and make sure you have
enough coverage on your home
you might have a home that was 400 000
and now it's 600 000 and you don't have
it covered but for 400
that'd be a bad thing if it burned right
so
you need to do this now here's the thing
while you're at it you might as well
check with our endorsed local providers
they are independent insurance agents
which means they will shop around a
bazillion different companies get you
the best price ever on your homeowners
and your car for that matter
and these p and c property and casualty
agents so this is the way to buy it when
you buy insurance from somebody like
state farm
that's a captive agent they can only
sell for one thing state farm so guess
what they're going to tell you you
should buy state farms stay farm that's
hard to figure out isn't it and by the
way it's more expensive so you can save
tons of money by shopping among a
different a group of different companies
and have an independent agent do that
for you go to ramsey solutions dot com
slash home talk to a trusted home
insurance pro today check out our
insurance property and casually endorsed
local providers they're ramsey trusted
ramsey solutions.com
home sheila is with us in seattle hi
sheila welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so okay uh here's my background i'm 48
years old i live near seattle um
single mom my son is about to finish
college he's
23
he'll be done um june of next year
our rent has increased it's currently at
1800
and then this coming september it's
going to be 21.50
and
i was so upset
anyway i do have um
20k of
uh emergency fund
100k
in money market that was originally
from the uh from trying to come up with
a down payment but
it's almost impossible
by the way i'm an rn i work from home as
an oncology nurse
and i make 123k
and
i got 201k 43b i got ross ira and so i'm
i'm needing some advice on my next step
i'm thinking why are you not buying a
house
well it's ridiculous here dave it's like
600k and that's not enough 20
in king county and and when i did move
to a descent county
um it still is about 400 to 500 so i'm
like even true she's got 100 to put down
i can't put that down is that's enough
sure
put it on a 15-year fix where the
payment's no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay
buy that amount of house
oh i doubted that i could find that
house but i said you work from home
right so you can you can move to a more
affordable area
i do i'm thinking just nearby counties
like
um just near my church yeah
i like that
and that's a cheaper area right
well it's just about 500 came yeah but
if you if you take out a 500 000 i mean
if you have a 500 000 house you put down
100 000 that's a 400 000 mortgage with
the money you make that ought to fit
really okay i was thinking i should have
that in mutual funds
no you i mean i thought you saved it up
for a down payment
yeah i mean that was the original intent
yeah but what happened was you watched
the news too much
stole your hope and insta and instagram
and you watched all these tick tock
economists
i was actually thinking david i need to
move in with
uh you know a friend or an acquaintance
and
you're not broke
you got no debt you make 120 grand
i know i was just thinking of saving up
more like 200k 300k and live with
somebody
a woman christian woman
meanwhile this house goes up in value
and it's harder and harder to purchase
okay so i should start looking then uh
okay yeah that's what i would do yeah
you don't you don't need to get an 800
000 house i'll go look for that four
hundred thousand dollar home that suits
you in a different county like you
mentioned and you got a three hundred
thousand dollar mortgage that's very
reasonable for your income and if you do
with our parameters there's no need to
stress when you look at the facts on
paper you go
oh i can breathe oh it could be fun to
like bring in a roommate when you did
that and now you're living for almost
nothing and you can pile up cash real
quick and move up in a few years that's
a good idea too you know meanwhile the
house you're living in is going up in
value it's a moving target there there
we go jessica's in south carolina hi
jessica welcome to the ramsay show
hey how's it going thank y'all for
taking my call sure how can we help
okay so i just found out about you guys
and the way to like start of getting out
of debt with the seven baby steps
however i currently have been living
paycheck to paycheck and i'm just now
going into a completely
different industry
and so i'm going from hourly of making
eighteen dollars an hour to now i'm
going to salary
starting out at fifty thousand
and then i'm losing way to go
and i'm also gonna be losing my roth ira
so i just don't know where to start
because due to the work change in
i'm having to relocate and living as
well
why are you losing the roth
because at my new job i
do not have the option oh you mean you
didn't lose your roth your right you
have if you have a roth it goes with you
but you just don't have a new one at the
new work and you have to do one on your
own but first first things first we're
gonna get you out of debt build up an
emergency fund have you done that
no sir i have i don't have any savings
okay so what kind of debt do you have
credit cards and a car
okay how much on the credit cards
16 000
and how much on the car
uh 23.
okay
what kind of car is this
a 2019 toyota rav4
okay
it is a it's a lot of car i mean it's
reasonable for your new income
uh what do you know what it's worth
um
i did like an appraisal on like carfax
and
i think they said it was going to be
around 24.
okay but the thing was i thought about
couldn't get you know a first sale and
like trading it in but i don't have
anything in savings
to where i could find you know a
reliable car yeah even with if i had a
savings and i don't have anything so i'm
just kind of like at ground zero and i
don't know where to go yeah let's
pretend you're not going to sell the car
you may end up selling it but for right
now we'll pretend you're not going to
sell it and make the move and now you're
going to get on a written budget
where every dollar has a name how old
are you 24
a no sir i'm 32. oh okay all right cool
well we're going to put you into
financial peace university our nine-week
class if we give it to you for free will
you take it
yes sir okay
so watch all nine lessons in there and
part of that you're gonna set up your
every dollar budget so you're gonna have
your income on one side which is your
you know take-home pay from that 50 000
salary on the other side you have all of
your expenses and i mean everything go
back and look at your bank account and
with the version we're going to send you
it'll actually connect to your bank
account which is going to be super
helpful and once you do that you're
going to go
oh okay at first it's scary because
you're looking in the mirror realizing i
thought i spent way less on clothes and
food and whatever else
once you do that i want you to create
enough margin to where you have extra to
put on that debt on those minimum
payments so list them all out smallest
to largest regardless of the interest
rate and we're gonna start attacking the
little one with a vengeance that might
mean getting a side job it might mean
cutting subscriptions it might mean
selling old stuff in the closet but it's
gonna get addicting and exciting and
soon you're gonna be debt-free it for
sure means you're not going on vacation
or going out to eat you're broken in
debt if you're gonna keep this car
you're gonna have to really sacrifice
and plow through these debts and get rid
of them oh by the way
when we hang up with you after austin
picks up i want you get the scissors out
and cut up your credit cards right now
they've been such a blessing
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personalities my
co-host today you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money here on
the ramsey show the phone number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
chase is with us in los angeles hi chase
how are you
hi i'm uh grateful to be alive how are
you guys same here brother what's up
um so i've been listening to you for
about a year now um and i listen to you
every day on my way to work i
pretty much dream and fantasize about
getting debt free and i'm having a hard
time diving full into your uh
program into the baby steps uh i'm a
recovering addict i'm a recovering
addict i've been
sober two and a half years good for you
and i just have to
thank you um i just have this giant fear
of losing everything and i have
you know like when i when i was on drugs
i you know was looking for change on the
streets had no money calling people for
money all hours of the night
and um now that i have you know a pretty
good savings at fifteen thousand dollars
in my savings i'm i'm really terrified
to let it go that you know i'll lose
everything like i did in my addiction
um
and i'm just kind of wondering what
advice you can give me to make that leap
of faith and just
go all in uh for you so what were you
addicted to
meth
whoa good for you that's a tough one to
break yeah proud of you how old are you
yeah it was really hard
i'm 33 wow
and what's your income now
um
well i
sell cars
used cars and
this year i'm on track to make 90 000 a
year good for you man that's amazing
you're amazing
thank you
thanks previous to that i was making uh
20 000 a year as a flight attendant
okay
yeah um so this big jump in income
has been pretty great for me
how much data
i have 58 000
in student loan debt i just cash flowed
my last semester
and
i have 21 000 in a car
i have
3 000
in collections
and i have uh twelve hundred dollars on
credit cards
okay
and that's it all right
well i'm very proud of you uh
breaking an addiction is a tough thing
breaking meth is a really super tough
thing
uh you're you're you're a man you're a
man that is beating the odds
i appreciate that and um and now you're
trying to address other behavior things
so here's the deal
when you were uh walking down the street
looking for quarters because you were a
meth addict
uh that's a different guy than i'm
talking to isn't it
it is okay yeah i mean but your body as
dr john deloney says your body remembers
the terror of being broke
yeah combined with the drug addiction
yeah it terrifies me yeah i know i have
a good head on my shoulders now um but
what my point is is the the thing that
is
welling up inside of you
then you physically feel it probably
is the you when you think about being
without that 15 000 it takes you back
you just told me this so i know it does
it takes you back to picking up quarters
on the street
yeah however you and i both know that
intellectually that is not the reality
the reason you were on the street
picking up quarters was meth it wasn't
15 grand
yeah if you'd had 15 grand you just
spent it on drugs
yeah and you're not that guy now
exactly yeah so our intellect tells us
that the facts are
chase is operating in a completely
different mindset in a completely
different world
than the terrifying thing that's keeping
him to move forward on this
does that make any sense yeah it does i
just needed to hear it i guess yeah so
you are more worthy than than your guts
tell you when you start talking about
pulling the 15 grand so i'm gonna do
something i almost never do here okay
i'm gonna modify
my advice a tiny bit
okay okay because i'm empathizing with
the way your heart rate is going up when
you're talking about this normally i
just call people a wuss and tell them to
bone up and do it right okay in your
case i'm going to do the same thing but
i'm going to give you 30 days
all right here's what we're going to do
today
i want you to pay off the credit card
and cut it up that's 1200
and the collections that's three
thousand dollars
okay now we really didn't affect your
cushion very much mathematically agreed
yes you're still sitting after you
finish that on 12 000 and some change
agreed
yeah so you're still okay breathe
but what that little experiment does is
i want you to get the high
oh that's a bad use of words i want you
to get the joy i want you to get the joy
of having paid off the debt
right okay okay and then you're gonna
compare that to the fear
from your past
all right and then i'm gonna tell you in
the next 30 days take the rest of that
money down to a thousand get your butt
on a budget and tear into this thing
like i would everybody else okay
okay but today and then one week from
the day i want you to sit down and write
out somewhere how it felt to pay off
those two debts because let me tell you
what you're going to feel i'll go ahead
and tell you
you're going to have a sense of power
empowerment yeah you're going to have a
sense of i'm in control
because part of being an addict is
you're out of control and you need a
sense of control to move forward into
your new self don't you
yes
yeah
and chase you you mentioned the sense of
security with the 15 000 but it's an
illusion because on the other side
you've got 84 000 in debt
and so there's not a place of safety
until you're completely out of that debt
and you work at a used car lot could you
sell the car and get a car off that lot
for nothing and drive that around while
you pay off the rest of this debt would
that give you another win
um i've i've thought about it i
i got an appraisal a couple days ago
they offered me 19 on my car i owe 22 i
think
if i cancel like the warranty and gap
insurance that i bought i could get it
close to 19.
yeah
and then i could possibly buy a
wholesale car from our wholesale lot we
get wholesale prices i've thought about
that now we're getting creative
and do that and do that with cash now
we're down to just a student loan
yeah you can use some of your savings to
even do that and get out from under this
car yeah go buy you a five seven
thousand dollar wholesale car
which is a ten or fifteen thousand
dollar car well it's not probably ten
thousand dollar car right buy it for
seven yeah and uh use some of that money
for that
now we're out of card debt now we're
just down to a student loan
and making 90k and making 90k this thing
out man
hey i smell success i smell it in the
air brother yeah
you got me excited there we go so here's
what you but and i think you're going to
be more excited when you actually wake
up and those two debts are gone you can
draw put them on the refrigerator draw a
big red line through collections a big
red line through the credit card oh you
got to cut up the credit card that's
part of the exercise okay
yeah i've uh cut up two of them yeah oh
you're not there yet this is all in
brother three credit cards which is all
in put it up right what i hang up that's
all in okay
yeah and i'll tell you what we want to
be part of the final steps of your
healing you have done such a wonderful
job in the journey that you're on you're
such an important guy right now uh we we
want to put you through financial peace
university so we're going to walk with
you while you do the rest of these
things
but
what you're going to experience there is
what people experience in the early days
of doing their debt snowball when you
pay off that little one you go yeah then
you pay off another one you're like yeah
and there's an emotional thing that
happens even though the math is small
because it's an action associated with
taking control of your destiny
and i can't wait for you to come do your
debt-free scream that's going to be a
powerful one yeah that'll be fun
and you can we'll pull this call up and
play part of it
and um you know a year two years from
now and
five years from now you're a baby steps
millionaire and man you'll have a
testimony what a story yeah story man
you're amazing could inspire a lot of
people way to go dude if you can beat
meth you can beat debt i mean that's
that's my line of the day oh that's a
billboard right this guy's impressive
way to go chase hang on austin will pick
up this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five two two five tiffany in new
york city hi tiffany how are you
i'm well how are you mr ramsay better
than i deserve what's up in your world
i thank you for taking my call i called
about a year ago and spoke to anthony
and dr john and they gave me some
wonderful advice and i'm happy to say
with god's good grace
that i became debt free before i turned
41. good for you uh the only thank you
the only debt i have left my husband and
i is our home
and i have three more years before i can
retire from my profession
and my question answer is
we're on the baby step number four
and i have a pension and annuity and a
457
and i'm contributing to my pension as
well as an extra fifty percent in
addition to what i have to contribute to
my pension as well as five percent to my
457 and i feel like i'm maybe not
contributing enough
50 percent
yes
of your income 50 yes
how are you not contributing enough if
you're putting in half of your income
i don't know if i should leave that
towards my pension or take that away
from the pension and put it towards my
457. i would put it in the 457.
because the pension dies when you do the
457 doesn't
okay
yeah but i don't know but it baby steps
four five and six you should be putting
15 percent
of your income towards
retirement
of your household income
and then everything above that should be
going to baby steps five and six your
kids college and paying off your house
you have kids in college or going to
college or anything
no we have a
two and a half year old and one who's
going to be one year old next month
great i would start at least start a
college fund for them and baby step five
fifteen percent of your income towards
retirement and then everything else
going to baby step six yeah i don't know
where the 50 is coming from it sounds
like you got some time i mean you got
three years here until you're saying
you're gonna retire but
it doesn't sound like a dire situation
right now 41 years old
too so yeah you have time and no i would
not be putting 50 50 percent of your
money away you're not going to be able
to live towards retirement um
until your home is paid off and then if
you wanted to get that aggressive at
baby step seven
when you're debt free everything then
you could if you wanted to
mckenna is in orlando hi mckenna welcome
to the ramsey show
hi how are you great what's up
hi so i just got offered today my first
full-time job out of college
thank you um 38 000 as a teacher at a
private christian school
um so i'll be going to sign the
paperwork tomorrow and i know that
there's 401ks and different things
um but i just want your opinion and
just what i should be looking for
um i don't think that there's a
teacher's union with it being a private
christian school but
anything else i should be looking for in
the paperwork
no i mean we love a 401k around here and
if you've got a roth option that's even
better and i don't want you doing that
until you're out of debt do you have
debt currently
i don't that's good news and you do you
have an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses
um i have three thousand dollars in an
emergency fund
okay well let's beef that up as you step
into this career and once you get to
that three to six month mark then we can
begin investing into whatever options
they have so i would do your research
see if they have a roth 401k and begin
investing 15 of your gross income and
inside of that 401k that's just a shell
so we want you to invest in good gross
stock mutual funds uh inside of that
401k
okay
so right now i actually have about
twenty thousand dollars invested with a
smart buster pro
um that i started
about a year and a half ago right um
because i've been following you guys
since like high school because i'm just
a geek over numbers wow um so is
is this something that i should combine
the money as far as 401k and
the mutual fund there get going no as a
matter of fact what i would do you need
to build your emergency fund so i'm
probably not signing up for the 401k
tomorrow when you do your paperwork
okay
i want you to go and get that 3 000 up
to three to six months of expenses and
you've been
geeking on our stuff so you knew we were
going to say that then what i would do
is take your 401k options the mutual
funds that
you're for maybe even be a 403 b
as a teacher in a private school okay
matter of fact likely is okay but it's
the same kind of a thing look at the
mutual fund options holler at your smart
vester pro
and ask them to look at the stuff with
you you might be better off just to
continue a roth ira with the smart
vester pro
than to deal with the 403 b if it's got
bad options or if it's not roth
okay
and then with ross isn't that where you
can't touch it for so many years all of
these are
okay gotcha 401k 403 b roth all of that
is 59 and a half for you can get to it
their retirement plans that's what
they're for
gotcha
the roth is just a type of tax treatment
where you're going to use your after tax
dollars to invest and it grows tax-free
yeah let your smartvestor pro guide you
in this and i think you'll end up in a
really good place first get your
emergency fund in place before you do
either one
good stuff well done
zach's with us in grand rapids michigan
hi zach how are you
hey what's going on dave how are you my
man i uh just wanted to say thanks for
letting me on here i got a sorry i got a
lot of respect for you and all that you
do man i've been listening to your
podcasts and reading some of your books
for
a few years now and i'm very grateful to
be here on the show with you well thank
you how can we help today
so long story short
i've been an investor now for a little
while
i am in real estate with my father
we own a llc where we have
our one zone neighborhood zones homes
within you know like a residential area
and then we also do vrbos and airbnbs
i find a lot of passion of that and i
get a lot of my income from that
so when i take that income and i invest
it i've been doing stocks for a little
bit here now and there and i've been
doing and again i think from your post
on facebook and different things you
might be a little skeptical but i've
been paying very close attention to
crypto
and i've been watching the chart
and in terms of financing this move that
i'm thinking of doing and this is why i
wanted your professional opinion because
i look at you as a role model i know you
got your stuff straight um i've been
doing and investing in schwab now uh
schwab investment account for the last
two two or so years and i've been
putting away about a grand every month
good friends and i also have a roth that
i put 500 into good for you so what i
was this is the main sorry go ahead no
you're gonna say your main question is
bitcoin
so yes that so i've been putting money
aside now for the last two years roughly
a grand every month and i have upwards
of so why do you want to lose a thousand
dollars that's the thing is i cuz
i've had mixed i've had mixed feelings
on it i've slept over it you know i've
talked to my father about it i've talked
to friends different investors that are
pro and against
um
well you're doing real estate investing
and you're doing mutual fund investing
which are both super conservative
investments
and then over here on the other side
you're talking about gambling
um which is where bitcoin is in a way no
it's not a little bit it's a lot
the probability of losing money in
bitcoin is very high
so i mean you can do what you want to do
boss you're asking should i take some of
this money i'm making and throw it into
bitcoin and the answer is no from us i
mean you said you've been listening to
the show for a while
neither dave and i invest in crypto
it has no track record that makes me
feel good about throwing money into it
i'd rather go to vegas at that point and
at least have some fun and be
entertained instead of staring at
the robin hood app watching it go 24 7
volatile up and down up and down so i'll
stick to my 401k iras real estate
that's the way that we talk about
building wealth around here we don't put
money in things that don't have a proven
track record
and um bitcoin's not been around long
enough to have a proven track record
and the track record that it has so far
has proven it to suck so far
um so when you have a proven track
record over many many years like decades
then we'll talk about it but you can do
whatever you want to do but it's just an
ultra high risk discussion the stories
i'm hearing about people destroying
their life over crypto
it's it's heartbreaking it's well and
it's all because i studied the charts
you know no thank you i you can do
whatever you want to do zach but all
this stuff you're doing sounds very cool
and very well done
the thing that doesn't fit in this
glaring situation is this one stupid
thing you're talking about doing so i
wouldn't do it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print and
the entree leadership podcast on ramsey
networks is my co-host today open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five eric is with us in lansing
michigan hi eric welcome to the ramsey
show
hello gentlemen uh mr ramsay it is an
absolute honor sir so uh thank you thank
you opportunity to speak with you and uh
thank you for your backwoods hillbilly
wisdom because you've changed my family
uh we've been debt free house and all
for a little while now so thank you very
much sir way to go man so you own a
house debt-free way to go
yes so i have a real estate question i'm
curious what 37 year old dave would say
so my in-laws currently have two houses
one in michigan and one in florida
they winter in florida so they're
snowbirds
they no longer want the maintenance and
upkeep of a house here in michigan so
they're selling it
my wife and i we've been looking at
purchasing a lake house
so my in-laws came to us with the
proposition of gifting us fifty percent
cash towards a down payment on a lake
house
the understanding is that they would
live with us or live at the lake house
during the summer months for three to
four months
and
the house would then be in our name
solely
so we have been saving for a house we
don't obviously don't have you know the
other 50 remaining but i'm curious what
your thoughts are on this
wow
very generous of them yeah
yes we have a very good relationship
okay so you're they're going to give you
how much money
fifty percent
what is that how much money is that
well i i don't wanna go over four
hundred thousand total for the purchase
okay so they're gonna give you two
hundred thousand dollars in return they
get to live in the lake house in the
summer which by the way is the only time
you can use it can you visit there can
you visit your lake house in the summer
yeah absolutely while they're there
we're looking at
you guys can go up and put the boat in
the water and all of you play and all of
you while they're living there in the
summer you'll be able to use it
yes it would be big enough for both of
us to be there in the summer and we
would utilize it in the winter too and
you've got kids
uh yes sir known as their grandkids
yeah and it's i'm like
this is great they're smart people okay
so you don't but you don't have the
other 200 grand
no not yet okay how long before you have
that
honestly it would probably take us
uh you know four to five years before we
got that well probably closer to four
okay
well lake house is a toy and i'm not
going in debt for a toy so
um and when i bought my lake house many
many many many years ago i didn't go in
debt for it
it's a total okay and so no no you don't
you got out of debt
yeah i know i i get it uh it's
it's uh
what's your income i guess
uh so my wife and i make about 140 000 a
year okay you don't have any payments so
i'm going what does it look like to
start looking once we have 100 grand and
they can put in
you know they put in 100 and we start
looking at more affordable options for
like houses and if it's not the right
one then we keep waiting until we have
the cash to do it and we can pony up 50
and 50.
yeah it's just really tough as far as
getting something that we want in that
price range at this point in time but no
i get where you're coming from is there
any urgency around this no he just wants
a lake house well of course i want a
lake house
who doesn't want a lake agreed i agree
i'm with you i'm 100 with you on that
three years of delaying this dream
you'll live right well or do it in some
other way but here's the thing
because because it's in a sense they're
they're putting the money on the table
now and that's pushing the urgency to do
it now and then and the fact that it's a
lake house and you're getting
half of the equity covered for you
it seems ludicrous not to borrow the
money to do it but i still am not going
to borrow the money to do a toy i'm
sorry dude i wouldn't do it
um okay if i were you you asked what i
would do and um and i can verify that i
would not do that because i did not do
that i saved up and paid cash because
you know again you're in michigan your
summers are short
and so you got three four months of use
a year
and you know and you're gonna pay
payments on that 12 months
so no
i um i wouldn't do that now um
what is these folks net worth
i have no clue
well if you were gonna guess 10 million
a million
oh
i
over a million but i i don't know beyond
that okay
so basically this money would be coming
from the sale of their michigan house
yeah probably yeah
okay
um
maybe they go by the lake house
when they sell it
the one that you all agree that you want
and you delay you and you say okay
i'd like to lock in that i can buy it
for half of that
uh when i can save up the money in a few
years meantime
you know we'll all use it together
right
yeah it's you know we were just looking
at this as an option it was proposed and
yeah you know so it's a wonderful one
it's a wonderful gift and a lot of
things but listen if you add up the
payments on 200 000
for the number of times that you're
there uh it's expensive you could go on
some really nice vacations it's
expensive and so um
yeah i i
i want you to be able to figure out a
way to do it but if it involves you
going into debt i'm i would not
personally do that and i would not
recommend it and i love the idea of you
having a lake house i love the idea of
them paying for half of it i love all
these ideas but i'm not ever going to
tell somebody go in debt for a toy and
this is it so on the real estate side
dave if the in-law is by the lake house
and he wants to buy them out of it what
is the right way to do that later they
could just deed it over to him okay he
hands them a check for 200k they buy a
400 000 lake house
and agree that when he ends them 200k
they hand him a deed
um and he starts saving his 200k and
buys them out in a few years on the same
deal plan just gives me a lot of peace
that's what you said i'm thinking papa
and granny here have some money but i
could be wrong that they might be able
to afford it in cash i don't know i
don't know if they can or not yeah um if
they're sitting on two or three four
million dollar net worth 400 grand is
not going to kill them
and they would plan on gifting this
anyway and so on so yeah
but it's ignorant no i would not tell
you to borrow money
thanks for the call open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
once you get out of that
once i got out of that
and i felt the freedom
there wasn't anything gonna get me back
in
but i had some temptations like he has
had over the years
you know we had a building the first
office building that we had we leased it
for five years
and i had an option to purchase it for
five million dollars when i did the deal
i didn't have any money hardly i mean i
had a net worth but i know five million
dollars
and i'm leasing it for five years well
during that time the building becomes
worth about 14 million wow and you still
have the opportunity right to buy it for
five million
and for five years i meant four years
and some change and i'm scratching
nickels out of the corner of the couch
trying to get the 5 million together
because i don't want to miss this i was
tempted
to to not walk away from all that equity
that was built into this option deal to
go borrow money
i'm borrowing money
i'm not borrowing money it's a sign from
god i'm not supposed to have it if i
don't have the money it's a simple thing
for me this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personalities my
co-host today this week we announced
that two of our building wealth events
for the fall have sold out
phoenix september 13th sold out
sacramento november 1st sold out
that leaves minneapolis with a few
tickets november the 10th san antonio
with a few tickets november 15th and we
open an extra night for phoenix we
cannot get extra nights in the other
cities so when they're gone they're gone
but i will be there september 12th for
phoenix and uh we launched it a couple
days ago it's already half sold out wow
so these things are going very very
quickly george these uh building wealth
live events are me and george and rachel
cruz and ken coleman dr john deloney uh
we'll talk to you about what's going on
in the economy what you've got to do to
build wealth we'll have a panel
discussion we'll be signing books taking
pictures hanging out and e these are all
like 3 000 person events type size
they're not super large they're not like
arena events uh big theater events and
but they do sell out very very quickly
and tickets are only 25 you can get a
four pack starting at 60 bucks at
ramseysolutions.com
events george this is exciting these are
selling out so fast i know and the
crowds have been amazing my favorite
part is just getting to meet people
after the event hear their stories and i
think it's a mix of the event is great
yes but people are also desperate to get
out of the house and go to events again
yeah and it's been amazing to see the
response to these it's interesting to
from an attendee's perspective to be in
an audience of 3 000 or 4 000 people
whatever it is
uh all people there with the same goal
which is actually you know taking
control of your own destiny building
wealth so that you can be generous and
there's just a shared
dream there and so it's not like a a mix
of people who don't want to win who are
victims or whatever it's all it's like a
pep rally for the stuff we do in a sense
and they're swimming upstream because
culture media they're telling people hey
you can't win in this economy you can't
beat inflation you can't build wealth
you'll never retire and we're over here
on our street corner just yelling going
it's possible you can do this stuff
ramsay solutions dot com slash events
get your tickets to these live events
we're also doing in dallas the smart
conference it is i think 65 sold out for
october 22nd already so if you want
tickets to that as well that's a
day-long event
uh with all of us
plus craig and amy groschel speaking on
marriage this year helen is with us in
chicago hi helen welcome to the ramsay
show
hi how are you thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up so um
my question is um we're ready to start
baby steps 4586
so i'm looking into
my retirement options i'm a teacher
and what my district provides are 403
b's and 457 and then rough options for
both and i'm not sure which one to take
for the roth options
better than a traditional right
for yeah roth is best and 403 b
okay i'm assuming you've got some good
mutual fund options in the 403 b have
you looked at those
yes they um i did a webinar last night
and then um i got some information on
that they have a vanguard index 500
they have a lot of they do have a lot of
them that i've heard you speak of online
or
on the podcast
um and i do want to look into those as
well good um they do have like targeted
ones as well yeah i wouldn't do that
okay
so yeah they do have mutual funds right
just straight up mutual funds and we
always tell you to put a fourth in each
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international your s p 500
falls in the growth category so it's
fine
that's one of your four if pick you out
a good international it'll be the worst
performing of the four categories
probably when you look at the track
record on it uh and aggressive growth or
emerging markets
it'll sound something like that and
that'll be the highest performing
but the most volatile and the boring one
will be the growth in income and that's
also sometimes called a blue chip fund
or a large cap
fund sometimes your aggressive growth is
called a small cap fund
oh okay
thank you so much thank you
congratulations it's an awesome place to
be yeah it's a great place if you go
across those four types george
um and and you pick ones that have good
long track records
you will have followed what we've been
teaching for 30 years and what the baby
steps millionaires
follow that caused them to become baby
steps millionaires and the third uh
ranking career teacher yeah that's true
that's exactly right good point good so
there you go she's on her way when we
did the study of millionaires we one of
the things we found as we studied ten
thousand millionaires was they the um
number one career most likely to be they
showed up the most often among
millionaires was engineer number two was
accountant number three was teacher
uh four was manager and five was lawyer
doctors mds didn't make the top five
there were number six
what are they busy doing spending money
impressing people
well docs are
i mean obviously they make a lot of
money so a lot of them become
millionaires but they're notorious for
stupid financial decisions i mean
they're
they're they're like like like music
artists or something i mean it's like
teachers have good heads on their nfl
players i mean you know it's that kind
of stuff not quite that bad but yeah but
they're they there's um
doc itis has with it an arrogance that
because you're a medical doctor you know
something about everything
and so they tend to uh
uh make bad financial decisions instead
of conservative traditional
that giant
i think they can figure out some kind of
risky investment yeah so not all of them
but some do yeah
uh
all right dallin is with us in phoenix
hey darling what's up
oh not much dave thank you for taking my
call i appreciate it sure how can we
help
um so you were just talking about
doctors and different things i'm uh
on pace right now to get into dental
school here in a couple years and i'm
just trying to
find out the best ways to
afford and pay for dental school we
don't have
enough saved up obviously to pay for
that in cash and
none of our families are going to help
us financially my wife and i
um and i know the military is a great
option
if we can get into the military and
do it through one of the branches that's
a great option but i was wondering if
either of you had any uh
idea of other places where i could start
looking to get some support there
so how much is this going to cost based
on your research
based on my research
here in arizona we don't have any public
dental schools
so if i leave the state i have to pay
out of state tuition so that raises
tuition up um so the cheapest that i
found for out of state is about 80 000 a
year
for dental school so you're looking at
320 350 at a minimum for just tuition
alone
how much money do you have saved
um right now we have
right around 50 000 in the bank okay and
what do you do for a living currently
um we we work college jobs i work at a
manufacturing early in the mornings and
my wife so you're you're in undergrad so
you're 23 or 22.
yeah i'm 23 years old yeah okay all
right
cool
well here here's the problem okay
uh
for some reason
and i really don't know what the reason
is um someone closer to the subject
probably could explain it to me
uh dental school is more expensive than
med school
which baffles the mind actually
um but um because dentists don't make
more than mds make um
you know by and large
uh so
uh
i i cannot tell you in good conscience
having worked with dentists for years
in
entree leadership helping them with
their practices helping them with their
business practices uh looking at these
things i i can't in good conscience tell
you to go 400 000 or 300 in debt to do
this i don't
i wouldn't personally
okay but is there a way to get at it
well like you said military is one uh
another thing is that there's a huge
movement and dental in the dental
world to for corporate dentistry a lot
of big companies uh corporate
conglomerates are buying up practices
and some of those might have
scholarship programs they might have if
you promise to work there or work for
them for so many years when you come out
type of a thing
i would trade out a few years after i
get out for free dental school
if i can find a company that would do
that
i don't know one to send you to but
there's a lot of movement in that
direction
be very very careful with this this is
very dangerous
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage john
and joy are with us hey guys how are you
great hello dave how are you better than
i deserve so good to have you guys where
do you all live akron ohio oh cool
welcome to nashville how much debt have
you paid off 76 thousand dollars all
right how long did that take
um about three years okay two and a half
three years all right very cool and your
range of income during that time
uh about 100 thousand dollars to about
110. cool what do y'all do for a living
i was in 19 and recently uh switched
careers to a vocational instructor oh
cool good for you and i work in cardiac
rehab oh good okay great what kind of
debt was the 76 000 everything you name
it uh credit cards mowers trucks
uh
student loans the whole bit so you were
like normal people normal normal
americans deeply in debt and got a good
mower yeah well
until even that wore out oh my gosh kept
the payments but got rid of the mower
oh
okay so what happened three years ago
that was the wake up call and how did
you get connected to this ramsey stuff
yeah we had um
i think the
the hot water tank uh was the big one it
was a emergency that wasn't planned for
and uh took a dive on us and we didn't
have any means to pay for it and it was
you know
it's just a hot water tank but it was
huge you know for us and um
and clay frankly when you can't provide
hot water for your family it kind of
does a little something to your man card
you know and your dignity and so that
set us off
um so you said you were done with the
credit cards at that point you went we
don't have the money for
life's emergencies we got to get on a
plan well the credit cards wouldn't even
let lonos money at that point so wow so
you maxed out the cards yeah wow so how
did you get connected to us at that
point
we had some friends that had mentioned
um an envelope system and not having
credit cards and
when we got to that point of hitting
rock bottom we said hey let's let's find
out who that guy was and so we did and
we got your book and we read it together
and
um instead of a thousand dollar
emergency fund we were shooting for an
eighteen hundred dollar emergency fund
because we had no hot water we're taking
some cold showers so
that'll put some pep in your step
on the plant so the first first first
order of business is get hot water yeah
yeah and uh yeah that's great yeah
that's amazing okay so total money
makeover book i guess yes okay yes and
that got you started on the whole thing
yep and then three years you slogged
through it huh yeah
yep okay we did a little door dashing we
did a little bit of
you know uh garage sale and you name it
i mean it was kind of our date night
sometimes door nation you know to make
an extra 300 bucks but
at the end of the day here we are and uh
it got us here so what was the hardest
thing to get rid of that you had to sell
or
i mean for me i'm the spender she's a
nerd um i
i sold a 1967
uh k guitar acoustic electric it wasn't
that cool it wasn't like it was like
gifts or anything but it was cool to me
you know vintage see that gets me i
thought you're going to say it was a car
and usually i go i can get rid of that
but a guitar that's that's tough for a
musician yeah wow
but it was worth the sacrifice oh
absolutely
yeah so what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is
remembering the why and for me
the why was that there was a time in my
life where i was so afraid and nervous
and anxious and felt like i was drowning
in debt and i don't ever want to go back
there again and i know there's people
out there that feel that way right now
and i just want to reach a hand out to
them and let them know you can do it and
we led our first fpu class this year wow
we even sponsored a couple we were able
to do that
they were in the middle of an emergency
when they started so
it just feels so good to be able to give
back that's the whole reason that's the
whole goal and actually even more
important than that we met god on the
way climbing out of our debt so very
cool yeah okay and we owe it all to you
very cool we're proud of you that's
awesome that's the best part of the
story right there amen excellent
excellent stuff amazing
cool so you're attending a good church
now we are what's your name what's the
name of the church uh fair haven church
rootstown ohio neat very neat good job
good job and all because of a hot water
heater amen
hot water god works in mysterious ways
he does
wow i like it that's great did the kids
get involved absolutely they each have
their uh give save spend envelopes
uh joey owns his own lawn care business
and was able to buy his first car all by
himself
what did he get what kind of car an
alexis is 250. whoa it's all and used
but hey got a lot of money though
that's that car's got a cool factor
though that's a good car
very cool and uh does he provide free
lawn care for you that's the real
question now that your mower's possible
we come last
he's your final customer
that's awesome you guys are heroes way
to go wow excellent job excellent job
okay
so the thing you want to make sure of is
tell people they can do it that there is
hope
um
[Music]
talk about the toughest moment
in this whole process where was the
toughest moment
the toughest moment for me was before we
started was at the beginning like not
even knowing that every day got a little
better after once you once you took
control of it once we sat down and did a
budget together it was just relief like
we had a plan
and we enjoyed our budget meetings we
did it weekly
every friday night was a win for us and
every every time that we had a victory
every time we paid off alone it was a
celebration and that motivated us it
kept us motivated very good yeah and you
know you talk about um feeling like you
gave yourself a raise you really do it's
amazing when you start
putting your money to work for you and
you being the boss of it rather than you
know it being the boss of you
how you can develop this or gain this
traction around
um you know trying to get out of it yeah
that's very cool all right now you're
leading a financial peace class people
hear you paid off 76 000 bucks
and they say well how did you do that
what do you tell them the main couple
things they need to do is
well i well you know like she said for
for me i think the biggest thing is
remembering your why remember the hot
water tank that took a crap on you and
trying to you know
make it right for not only the moment
that you're in but also the long-term
outcome for you and your family
um
and and then i think self-denial or
denying yourself you know discipline
everyone around us has brand new cars
ours are 15 years old so yeah you know
just discipline yeah but you're free we
are free amen how's it feel
beautiful wonderful unbelievable we're
proud of you you guys are amazing very
very well done good words good words
a lot a lot of people inspired by your
story heroes absolute heroes very well
done got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story you're on your way
how ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too
and a copy of total money makeover for
you to give away to somebody uh you're
going to run into somebody this week
probably
and we'll go ahead and give you a
one-year subscription to our membership
to financial peace university and you'll
be able to give scholarship somebody in
the next class that way if you're very
that's fun yeah good stuff yeah thanks
for leading the class that's awesome we
appreciate that very very good yeah
you'll be changing some people's lives
by doing that it's important important
stuff you guys are impressive very well
done all right so joseph and lexi are
how old
16 and 12. all right very cool very well
done you guys all right john and joy
joseph and lexi akron ohio 76 000
paid off in three years making 100 to
160 met god on the journey count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
two
one
we're
[Applause]
that's how it's done he counted that
down like a band leader that was amazing
they've been practicing
good stuff that's changing the family
tree the kid's buying his car with cash
he's starting his own business he's
catching on to this thing rock stars man
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalm 139 16
you saw me before i was born
every day of my life was recorded in
your book every moment was laid out
before a single day had passed
mark twain said the two most important
days in your life are the day you were
born and the day you find out why
[Laughter]
good stuff george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today bill's
in green bay hi bill how are you
good thank you uh so my wife and i are
always looking for the most worthwhile
places to donate money and we currently
donate to our church and a couple of
other organizations but we
we're looking to make a bigger impact
for a family
and we decided we'd like to donate money
to a couple that we know to help them
pay for college for their 14 year old
when she goes to college in a few years
and
now we're friends with this couple but
not extremely close and we feel that
this is an excellent place to donate
money and have a big impact the child is
has extreme potential
and my question is number one what is a
good way to sell this idea to them i
know that well there are no absolutely
no strings attached and we aren't
looking for any recognition but i've
realized this has a potential to seem
off-putting if we approach it in the
wrong way
and number two if we do go through with
this what is the best way to go about it
uh would we just give them a check so
they can open a 529 plan or open one
ourselves are there any tax implications
associated with this
yeah what a big heart bill way to go man
that's awesome thank you so how much
money are we talking about donating to
this child's college
uh ten thousand good for you okay
all right thank you um what i would do
is contact a smart investor pro
and um get everything all set up but
don't open it get it ready to go
select the mutual fund
figure out the 529 plan
get everything set up uh you will if i
were in your shoes i would list the
parents as the custodian
of the money which means they're in
charge of the money
okay okay um and then i would uh take
them to dinner
and just sit down and go okay this is a
little weird
this is so just you know the best way to
keep something that's awkward from being
super awkward is just say it's awkward
and that kind of takes the awkward power
away right
yes and just go this is strange i've
never done anything like this i i know
if i do this wrong it could be
off-putting and just say the exact same
things you just said to me
and unless these people are psychotic
they're not gonna be put off they're
just gonna go wow we are so grateful
thank you so much for that you didn't
have to do that i mean do you know about
their financial situation
uh slightly
um
i i think that this
this would be um very grateful yeah yeah
i think it's because it's for the child
and for college it feels different than
hey you guys are broke here's some money
to be less broke this feels like you
care about this child and their future
and you're investing i mean into that
let me tell you as a parent um
it's hard to not like someone that's
doing something nice for your kid
yeah if you're mad at generosity
especially for for their child that's a
that's a weird thing but i mean yeah you
you know and i think i would just couch
it and say listen there's no strings
attached
i've got it all set up you will be in
charge of the account as the custodian i
have not made the deposit and done the
final
stroke on the paperwork yet but it's all
set up with a smart vester pro from ram
you know one of the people ramsey
recommends
and uh it's ten thousand dollars of
being a mutual fund and uh then you're
in charge of it and we're gonna hand the
paperwork over to you and we're gonna
walk away and it's gonna be under your
control
and uh got lots of suggestions
and lots of ideas but none of those are
part of this deal
okay
that
that sounds good i i appreciate that
i've had a great deal of anxiety about
how to approach this and you just say
that out loud
and you know what they'll go yeah i kind
of understand because it's not like
we're best friends it's not like we're
family members
uh this is a little weird but it's
wonderful weird
well thank you that's good to hear yeah
and that's i i think when you say that
out loud then everybody's not sitting
around going okay why does this feel
strange to me and no one's acting like
it's strange you know
because it is strange but it's a
wonderful strange so but it takes the
the all the awkwardness and the anxiety
and all that stuff goes away as soon as
you say it out loud
yes
that sounds right i hadn't thought of it
that way but that does make sense yeah
hey thanks for the call we appreciate
you guys
the baby steps and thanks for being busy
kind of generosity everybody ought to be
bill
i mean
there you go live like no one else so
later you can put ten thousand dollars
in an account for a kid that's got big
potential that you sort of know
i love it that's called generosity right
there boys and girls that's a big time
move
that that's that's a pro hack right
that's inspiring it makes me want to do
that one day yeah it's very very cool
very very good stuff
yeah anytime you're having
money conversations or any other
conversation for that matter that's
awkward
um when my kids were teenagers there was
a thing they would do like awkward
turtle oh i remember that remember that
yeah
and they would just go okay awkward
turtle and this this is awkward
conversation just give me permission um
like a turtle that's upside down can't
get over i don't know how they did their
hands but it was like something like
that and um yeah and it was golly wow
but i mean it does it's just like okay
this is just defuse the temperature
sometimes you know we're teaching
leaders to do uh
to sit with someone where there's going
to be a
difficult conversation how to have
difficult conversations
and one of the best things you can do
when you're having a difficult
conversation with a team member and
you're saying as their leader you're
going hey
this is going to be a difficult
conversation get ready here we go and
all of a sudden it's a little bit less
difficult there's still some hard truth
there's still some things that have to
change for you to get to stay working
here there's still you know we're still
gonna have to be have some clarity and
have to have some change in behaviors or
whatever it is but
you're gonna know
and you're not getting fired today
and but this is going to be tough so you
know buckle in there buttercup here we
go and confusion all of a sudden it
takes some of the weirdness out of the
air on those types of things brian is
with us brian is in cincinnati ohio hi
brian how are you
hey great guys how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
my wife and i are in the process of
looking for a new house to buy i'm just
trying to figure out how much house we
can afford
um we make about 40 a year we clear
about 7 500 a month we own a house
currently that we owe 57 000 on could
probably sell it in
around 180 house
for 190 in our neighborhood but
it's just the numbers i'm going off of
we don't any other debt
good
okay i wouldn't want your payment we
teach
okay you can qualify for a lot more than
we're going to tell you to do
great but we have some conservative
guidelines george yeah so we're looking
at 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
and uh no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay
and then you can decide how much down
payment that is uh obviously i want you
to put down as much as possible and get
a reasonable house so once you start
yeah whatever the number is that the
loan qualifies for based on that and the
rates are probably
about four and three quarters or
something like that on 15. you have a
15-year fixed you're looking probably
close to five at this point yeah and so
you know plus you got 120 000 bucks
coming out of this house
right yes so what kind of house are you
looking to get have you done the
research in your area of what you yeah
yeah we've done a little bit um the
houses are going for around like 350
that's probably i'm thinking the top of
our budget or too much but that's kind
of means we're looking at just for an
upgrade we're just hooking the house we
don't want to make a lateral move to a
nicer neighborhood to the same size
house you said your take-home pay is 7
500.
yeah you're looking at 1875 would be
kind of your top limit so i'm just
crunching numbers here and i'm going
okay well 1875 you'd probably need to
put down 180 grand on a 350 000 home in
order to do this and uh have it not be
too much that means you're probably
buying a 320 000 house instead of a what
based on the numbers we got here
something like that so we adjust our
expectations or we save longer yeah give
or take a little bit because you've got
120 to put down out of your house unless
you've got some other monies to put with
it you might have
but again a fourth of your take-home pay
in payment
on a 15-year fixed and that keeps you
from having
bit off so much house that you can't
fool around get it paid off we want the
margin in your budget so you can get it
done good hour george well done thanks
dave well done kelly
andrew zach ben austin all the team in
the booth i am dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you